[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
janna paris bekommen und einen schönen
guten abend herzlich willkommen eine
deutsche medaille und mehr im sport mit
norbert lehmann junior familie unter
anderem auf diese themen schauen wir
heute
angst vor der gasknappheit ein gipfel in
stuttgart sucht wege durch die krise
zusammen mit vielen gesellschaftlichen
gruppen
bitte um vergebung in kanada trifft
papst franziskus indigene sie waren in
katholischen einrichtungen viele
jahrzehnte lang gewalt ausgesetzt
und lichtblick in einer ernüchternden
bilanz bei der leichtathletik wm gewinnt
nur weitspringerin malaika mihu gold für
das deutsche team
[Applaus]
russische gaslieferungen sind zurzeit
wenig verlässlich das zeigt sich heute
wieder so kündigte gazprom an ab
mittwoch die lieferungen durch nord
stream 1 auf 20 prozent zu senken
die begründung eine turbine müsse
gewartet werden das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium sieht
keinen technischen grund wie deutschland
mit einem gas mangel klarkommen kann
darum ging es heute bei einem
krisengipfel zu dem die landesregierung
baden württemberg eingeladen hatte jan
frederik fischer
nun also doch moskau dreht weiter am
gashahn ab mittwoch sollen die
lieferungen durch die ostseepipeline
nord stream 1 halbiert werden statt 40
würden dann nur noch 20 prozent strömen
die bundesregierung reagiert und zwar
mit unverständnis aus dem
bundeswirtschaftsministerium heißt es
wir haben die ankündigung zur kenntnis
genommen es gibt nach unseren
informationen keinen technischen grund
für die reduktion der lieferung es ist
eine zeit voller unsicherheiten ein
grund mehr antworten auf die drohende
gaskrise zu finden in baden württemberg
will man daher heute geschlossenheit
demonstrieren mit einem gas gipfel mit
dabei wirtschaft kommunen gewerkschaften
alle an einem strang ziehen
wirtschaft öffentliche verwaltung aber
auch privatverbraucher 15 bis 20%
gasverbrauch
einzusparen dann besteht die berechtigte
hoffnung und zuversicht dass wir nicht
in eine gasmenge lage geraten
die lage ist ernst in allen
bundesländern auch bundesnetzagentur
chef klaus müller mahnte heute mit blick
auf die ziele des bundes die gasspeicher
bis zum winter zu 90 prozent zu füllen
sei nicht realistisch gegen die krise
könnten auch atomkraftwerke helfen stand
jetzt laufen sie ende des jahres aus
doch die debatte nimmt weiter an fahrt
auf auch kanzleramt legte man sich am
mittag nicht final fest wartet einen
neuen stresstest ab es ist aber auch
klar dass die regierung in diesem falle
in dieser neuen lage in der wir uns
befinden
vollkommen ideologiefrei und
ergebnisoffen schaut was vernünftig und
angemessen ist die zeit drängt antworten
müssen her denn keiner weiß wie lange
und wie viel gas von russland nach
deutschland fließen wird
während die politische diskussion läuft
ob deutschland direkt kampfpanzer in die
ukraine liefern sollte sind heute die
ersten drei deutschen luftabwehr panzer
vom typ gepard in der ukraine
eingetroffen
deutschland wird das land gerade mit
humanitärer hilfe künftig noch stärker
unterstützen so heute innenministerin
phaser und arbeitsminister heil bei
ihrem besuch in der ukraine
christoph distel über die kriegslage und
das wackelige getreide abkommen
das getreide wartet nicht auch im don
was muss jetzt geerntet werden am
horizont tobt derweil der krieg ein
ukrainischer jet bombardiert russische
stellungen wird dabei selbst geschossen
vor dieser fast unwirklichen kulisse
kommt in der ukraine gerade immer mehr
getreide zusammen zusätzlich zu den
schon eingelagerten 20 millionen tonnen
aber keine sorge verspricht der kreml
heute erneut man werde sich an den
vereinbarten export halten
und mit blick auf die pipeline nord
stream 1 verspricht moskau zumindest
dies
sobald die reparierte turbine wieder
eingebaut ist wird so viel gas geliefert
werden wie technisch möglich
getreide für die welt gas für europa
vielleicht sicher ist im moment nur die
kämpfe gehen weiter vor allem im donbass
aber auch im russisch besetzten süden
bei person
seit tagen nimmt sich die ukraine dort
eine gegenoffensive vor dieses video
soll zeigen wie ihre artillerie die
besatzer weit hinter der frontlinie
getroffen hat aber echte geländegewinne
kann derzeit offenbar keine seite melden
dabei ist zumindest das russische
kriegsziel jetzt wieder glasklar
formuliert von verteidigungsminister
lavrov auf seiner afrika reise
wir werden den ukraine definitiv dabei
helfen ihr regime loszuwerden das
absolut volksfeindliche ist und
historisch nicht legitimiert
präsident zielinski kontert erfahrung in
sachen selbstbestimmung kultur identität
all das ist bei uns mehr als 1000 jahre
alt zwei sichtweisen wie sehr die zweite
auch die deutsche ist das unterstrichen
innenministerin feser und
arbeitsminister heil über nacht waren
sie mit dem zug nach kiew gereist
versprachen im zerstörten ihre bienen
mehr hilfe mehr solidarität vor allem
beim wiederaufbau
zu corona da sind wir mitten in einer
sommer welle das robert koch institut
meldet trotz unsicherer datenlage viel
mehr infektionen als in den letzten
beiden jahren einschränkungen gibt es
aber kaum mehr jetzt nimmt wegen der
vielfachen personal not die diskussion
fahrt auf ob man sich überhaupt noch
isolieren soll wenn man infiziert ist
aber keine symptome hat die
krankenkassen warnen es werden immer
wieder mehr menschen wegen corona
krankgeschrieben soll diskussion butter
spiekermann
personal fehlt im moment fast überall
besonders natürlich in kliniken aber
nicht nur da kitas im notbetrieb oder
gleich ganz geschlossen engpässe auch im
hotel & gastro gewerbe isolations und
quarantäne pflichten reißen löcher in
die ohnehin gespannte personaldecke
schluss mit den starren regeln sagt der
chef der kassen ärzte krone infizierte
ohne symptome könnten arbeiten man müsse
zurück zur normalität
wir hätten vielleicht in teilen wieder
ein funktionierendes land will wir sehen
ja dass in allen bereichen ist ja nicht
was gesundheitswesen sondern überall
durch diese hohen
fehlerquoten die ja nicht durch kranke
stellen dass unsere figuren die sie bei
tests in weiten teilen begründet sind
weite teile verschiedenster
infrastrukturen nah an die
dysfunktionalität kommen und das kann
man ja nicht sehen und ist jetzt noch
monate weiter schön karl lauterbach
kontert scharf und weiß dabei die grünen
an seiner seite die fdp hingegen spricht
von einem wichtigen vorstoß der minister
bleibt dabei kein ende der regelung wenn
wir die isolation pflicht abschaffen
würden das würde bedeuten dass auch
infizierte zur arbeit gehen oder
beispielsweise sich privat also treffen
das heißt infektionsketten würden viel
länger werden dann nach sehr kurzer zeit
noch deutlich mehr interessierte als wir
hier zu haben sodass wir insgesamt eine
verschärfung der pandemie angesichts
steigender fallzahlen und hoher
dunkelziffer rät auch virologisch
stürmer dringend jetzt nicht von regeln
abzuweichen
personalprobleme würden sich sogar
verschärfen
unsere ganzen sicherheitskonzepte in den
betrieben sind darauf ausgelegt
infizierte mitarbeiter eben nicht im
betrieb zu haben und jetzt lassen heiße
wieder in die betriebe rein strömen dann
wird das ein domino effekt haben dass
wenn sich sukzessive mehr menschen
anstecken und ich habe eigentlich gar
nichts gewonnen die debatte über die
isolation pflicht ist nicht der einzige
streitpunkt innerhalb der ampel
regierung in sachen coruna im herbst
soll ein neues infektionsschutzgesetz
stehen um mit betrügereien bei corona
testzentren beschäftigt sich heute abend
die wiso sendung um 19 25
endlose schlangen beim check-in und dann
führt am ziel auch noch das gepäck
fliegen es oft kein vergnügen in diesem
sommer und am mittwoch wird es zumindest
für lufthansa-passagiere eine weitere
hürde geben die gewerkschaft verdi hat
das bodenpersonal der fluglinie zu einem
deutschlandweiten und ganztägigen
warnstreik aufgerufen
sie will damit in der laufenden
tarifrunde ihre forderung unterstreichen
9,5 prozent mehr lohn auch um die
belastung der beschäftigten in
krisenzeiten zu honorieren und am
frankfurter flughafen ist für uns markus
wolsiffer markus was heißen dass für die
flughäfen
ja das heißt vor allen dingen noch mehr
belastung in einer ohnehin angespannten
situation der streik soll am mittwoch
früh 3 uhr 45 staaten und am donnerstag
um 6 uhr am morgen enden verdi wirft der
lufthansa vor mitverantwortlich für das
chaos an den flughäfen zu sein die
lufthansa wiederum sagt dieser streik
der ist unvernünftig den kann man in
diesen situationen nicht an den tag
legen im konzern hat man tatsächlich in
den vergangenen tagen eher damit
gerechnet dass man zu einer lösung
findet jetzt also eine eskalation in
diesem konflikt und es wird interessant
zu sehen sein welche dynamik dieser
streik auf die tarifverhandlungen
insgesamt nehmen wird natürlich ein
streik ist legitim aber in diesen
schwierigen momenten hat er natürlich
eine besondere wucht und es wird die
reisenden treffen aber auch die
lufthansa verdi lässt die muskeln
spielen und das werden viele spüren ab
mittwoch dankeschön markus weise vor
über den kommenden warnstreik danke
ja was tun wenn es bei ihrem flug
probleme gibt wie lässt sich der urlaub
retten möglichst ohne verluste antworten
zum reiserecht geben der kurz und
verständlich online jederzeit unserer ze
erfreute
und wir blicken nach kanada dort ist
gerade der papst auf busreise wie er
selber sagt angesichts der verbrechen
die die katholische kirche dort gegen
die indigene bevölkerung verübt hat
zwischen dem 19 jahrhundert und mitte
der 1990 er jahre wurden rund
150.000 indigene kinder unter zwang von
ihren familien getrennt und der
katholischen einrichtung gefoltert
vergewaltigt und geschlagen tausende
starben ein bericht von mrt wissen
ein moment der demut auch der charme
papst franziskus betet auf dem land der
ureinwohner kanadas die kreuze klagen
aber die menschen im rund neben dem
friedhof erwarten mehr als demut weil
das was die kirche zuließ und später
vertuschte so unsagbar schrecklich ist
edmund mit tauben erinnert sich die
priester die kinder im sentence internat
in fort aber nie aus peitschten sie für
ungehorsam auf einem elektrischen stuhl
bestraften in medias er war aus metall
mit rad angeschlossen wir sollten ihn
festhalten und dann schalteten sie den
strom ein wir waren sechs sieben jahren
im exil in den katholischen internaten
kanadas wurden über 100 jahre rund
150000 kinder der indigenen völker
umerzogen ihrer kultur beraubt
misshandelt missbraucht
4000 starben viktoria macintosh hat die
hölle auf erden erlebt ihre eltern boden
gezwungen sie mit vier jahren ins
internet zu bringen wo nonnen den
priestern nachts mädchen zu führten
er missbrauchte mich auf eine art die
kein kind je durchleiden sollte
immerhin im beisein der anführer der
ältesten der indigenen nationen will der
papst in diesen minuten die
verantwortung übernehmen und um
verzeihung bitten die kunden sollen
heilen aber einige der täter sind immer
noch auf freiem fuß trotz des leids das
so vielen anteil
nach der zerstörung von gedenkt bäumen
in der nähe der kz gedenkstätte
buchenwald ist bundesweit die empörung
groß thüringens ministerpräsident
ramelow verurteilte die taten und will
seinen urlaub unterbrechen um sich an
der neupflanzung von bäumen zu
beteiligen unbekannte hatten vergangene
woche sieben bäume abgesägt die an
ermordete häftlinge und kinder erinnern
sollten zwei weitere wurden am
wochenende zerstört und beschädigt
inzwischen haben eine rettungsaktion für
die bäume und nachpflanzungen begonnen
in tunesien stimmen die wahlberechtigten
heute über neue verfassung ab ihr ziel
mehr rechte für den präsidenten und so
befürchtet die opposition weniger rechte
für die bürgerinnen und bürger dabei
waren die in dem nordafrikanischen land
hart erringen worden ende 2010 begann
dort proteste gegen die staatsführung
die auf viele weitere staaten
übergriffen beginn des sogenannten
arabischen frühlings doch nur tunesien
gelang der wandel zu freien wahlen zur
demokratie bieber scheint präsident
jetzt ernsthaft infrage zu stellen
thomas walter
es ist keine gewöhnliche abstimmung die
heute morgen in den wahllokalen
tunesiens begannen die anhänger des
präsidenten wollen eine neue verfassung
die ihm völlige kontrolle über das land
wird
den armen ich habe ja für sie abgestimmt
ist damit er mit der misere gründlich
aufräumen
dabei hat präsident karsai jetzt bereits
seine befugnisse ausgeweitet das
parlament ist geschlossen seit sajed
expandiert hat und zahlreiche richter
hat er per dekret entlassen
haben was passiert ist dass der
präsident den dialog mit der
zivilgesellschaft blockiert hat und ganz
auf sein
kritiker sprechen darum von einem putsch
und rufen zum boykott der heutigen
absolut auf
sondern nur mal
die opposition ist gegen dieses
referendum es hat keine legitimität weil
das ergebnis vorher bereits
dabei war tunesien 1 eine hoffnung die
einzige demokratie nach dem arabischen
frühling doch viele menschen verbinden
heute mit demokratie eine
wirtschaftliche dauerkrise
das leben ist zu teuer geworden ich kann
mir nicht mal mehr tomaten kaufen viele
sind zu müde die demokratie zu
verteidigen
möglich ist dass unabhängig vom
abstimmungsergebnis auf den arabischen
frühling auch in tunesien ein arabischer
winter folgt
in süd europa leiden die menschen weiter
unter der extremen hitze und waldbränden
in griechenland kämpft die feuerwehr
sowohl im nordosten in der region evros
als auch im südwesten gegen die flammen
seit tagen wüten auch auf der insel
lesbos waldbrände mehrere tausend hektar
sind bereits verbrannt und auch in
italien machen sich lang anhalten der
hitze und dürre bemerkbar allein in der
region umbrien setzt die feuerwehr
löschflugzeuge gegen neun verschiedene
brände ein
es ist wieder soweit in bayreuth auf den
grünen hügel beginnen die richard wagner
festspiele mit fünf stunden tristan und
isolde
es ist ein radikales stück über liebe
und über weltflucht bei den proben hat
corona so einiges durcheinandergewirbelt
einschränkungen für das publikum gibt es
aber nicht und für heute nachmittag
ging's los war luc
premierenfieber roter teppich knapp 40
grad
beherzt schreiten die damen und herren
ins nicht klimatisierte festspielhaus es
ist auch ein treffen alter bekannter
heute premiere für tristan und isolde
die neue inszenierung ist eine flammende
hommage an die liebe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich hole meine bestätigung aus unserer
sehr speziellen zeit also in dieser sehr
krisen durch schüttelten zeit
muss es möglich sein wieder raum für
sehnsucht zu schauen
was war das hier für eine probezeit
erschüttert durch corona sexismus
vorwürfe sänger absagen
dirigentenwechsel
aber er ist verlässlich da steven gold
heldentenor und kraftpaket gleich drei
wuchtige partien sinkt er hier heute
abend den tristan das geht nur mit
disziplin
ich bin eigentlich ein mensch
geworden ich gehe jetzt nach hause ich
schlafe ich mache meine eigene essen und
da nicht immer zurück
und fünf wochen wird sich hier nun alles
um liebe macht und mythen drehen
bevor wir zum sport kommen noch eine
kurze richtigstellung in unserem ukraine
beitrag hat der autor lawrow
versehentlich als russischen
verteidigungsminister bezeichnet er ist
natürlich außenminister diesen fehler
bitten wir zu entschuldigen und nun
kommen wir zum sport wie angekündigt ist
es der abschluss der leichtathletik-wm
norbert und da gab es jetzt die erste
und einzige grund ja wenigstens auf
unsere wald springerin neue lambo ist
verlass er hält was der titel
erfolgreich verteidigt und eine
topleistung gezeigt was man sonst vom
deutschen team nicht sagen kann wie
hamburgs gold hat die schlechte dlv
bilanz allenfalls etwas aufgehübscht
der vierte titel bei großereignissen
nacheinander der zweite bei einer wm für
maliki hamburg alles andere als
selbstverständlich 1 titels erreichen
ist schon nicht leicht aber denen dann
auch noch zu halten und zu verteidigen
macht das ganze wirklich besonders und
da bin ich sehr glücklich drüber im
vierten versuch springt sie zu gold im
letzten untermauert sie mit 712 ihre
jahrelange ausnahmestellung in der welt
keine chance auf die titelverteidigung
hat zehnkämpfer niclas kohl trotz seines
starken zweiten tages reicht es am ende
nur zu platz sechs abseits der
medaillenränge überhaupt überwogen die
fehltritte in eugene aus deutscher sicht
einmal bronze in der staffel
da hilft auch das gold von malaika mir
haben wir nicht das ergebnis des
deutschen verbandes bleibt das
schlechteste abschneiden in der
wm-geschichte und
zwei weltrekorde gab es noch zum
abschluss der wm am boden und in der
luft stabhochspringer arman geplantes
aus schweden holte seinen ersten
freiluft wm titel und übersprang mit 621
seine eigene bestmarke um zwei
zentimeter
ja und über 100 meter hürden lief die
nigerianerin tobia mosaik bereits im
halbfinale sagenhafte 12,1 sekunden
weltrekord
zur fußball-em da treffen die deutschen
frauen damit wir auch im halbfinale auf
frankreich das dfb team nach der
erfolgsserie von vier siegen in vier
spielen und nur gegentreffern
hochmotiviert und siegessicher
frankreich kennerin sara däbritz seit
drei jahren in der französischen liga
gibt deutschland ein versprechen wir
werden alles geben für unser land um uns
den traum erfüllen zu können auch wenn
die deutschen im viertelfinale nicht
ihre beste turnierleistung zeigten beim
2 0 über österreich so strotzen sie doch
vor selbstbewusstsein und bauen auf
ihren unbändigen willen der sie
letztlich ins halbfinale gebracht hat
die haben wir so eine tolle energie in
der mannschaft entwickelt zum tollen
teamgeist und ja ich kann ihnen
versichern dass wir bei dem spiel 1000
prozent geben wollen und werden und dann
hoffentlich ins finale einziehen die
französinnen allerdings haben dasselbe
ziel
sowohl war der final spiel live zu sehen
im zdf mittwoch 20.15 ist in arbeit auch
diese woche hat er wieder sehr heiß
begonnen jetzt kommen schauer und
gewitter mehr dazu gleich von katja
horneffer christian sievers begrüßt um
21 45 zum heute journal
[Musik]
guten abend die hitze für einen tag wird
jetzt weg geräumt von einer kaltfront
dieses tiefs hierbei großbritannien vor
der kaltfront entwickelten sich heute
schon kräftige schauer und gewitter und
mit denen haben wir es jetzt auch am
abend zu tun und in der nacht die ziehen
über norddeutschland hinweg aber auch
über die mittelgebirge da können schwere
sturmböen dabei sein und in der zweiten
nachthälfte ziehen auch gewitter aus den
alpen heraus weiter nach nordosten die
eigentliche kaltfront kommt dann hier
von der nordseeküste heran aber zwischen
dem harz und dem hunsrück bleibt die
nacht wohl eher die temperaturen sinken
in der lausitz und in niederbayern auf
19 grad deutlich kühler wird zum
beispiel im westerwald mit zwölf grad
und morgen bleibt es dann kühl an der
see da liegen die höchstwerte nur bei 18
bis 20 grad sonst werden um die 25 grad
erreicht und am wärmsten wird er im in-
oder auch am oberrhein am vormittag kann
es am alpenrand noch letzte schauer und
gewitter geben dann wird es auch dort
freundlicher
in norddeutschland sind die wolken
insgesamt etwas dichter und da gibt es
auch einige regenschauer bei
nordwestwind damit wird trocken und bis
zum ende der woche nimmt dann die
gewitterneigung von tag zu tag wie dazu
bei sommerlichen temperaturen
guten abend